but like Joe man we [ __ ] with Joe Hardy
[ __ ] on that sober October thing yeah oh
yeah when he was doing on I remember he
came in as Kevin the colony started he
seemed kind of like upset I was like
what's going on he's like I've had to do
yoga for 30 days let me tell you let me
tell you something about [ __ ] Rogan
and by the way well and just because of
these internet goddamn trolls I love Joe
Rogan he's one of my closest friends but
man when he when we started doing that
over October thing this is how it went
down okay it was all about me everyone's
gonna do it but then orient Tom said
they'd be into it and and we thought it
was a thing a collective with Joe so I
cut this video and in the video it's me
running through the forest and I go this
sober octo so October me and my friends
to titty Tom re the well Shaffir and Joe
and powerful Joe Rogan will all be when
it's over I send it to Joe before I post
it and I go hey just making sure
everyone's cool with this Joe didn't
reply right and so we're like he took
that as he ya know so cigar and Tom and
I are like sugar in our in our like
weight with no reply from Joe huh and
then our he's like wait Joe's doing it
right so he sends a text and Joe's like
no [ __ ] you guys I don't have a problem
you guys [ __ ] suck you guys are doing
it and then Ari's then already mounts
the [ __ ] attack campaign he text us
independently he goes yo I'm taking down
Joe you are with me now sucker is such a
[ __ ] [ __ ] even when we [ __ ] right
Ari's like I'm gonna post a video I want
your comments to be the first two
comments on Instagram huh
and I know we're gonna workshop them so
they're aggressive enough that Joe has
to reply right so I write mine I guess I
really don't have a problem Joe's got
the problem he can't give up marijuana
whatever I said you know he needs it to
eat his dinner if you need marijuana eat
your dinner you've got a problem
and this is a girl right says it's very
such a [ __ ] [ __ ] he's like he's like
powerful Joe Rogan doesn't need to give
up anything he's the greatest human
being in the world whatever the [ __ ] you
said it was like that right right aryen
are like no [ __ ] you
we're writing yours yeah and you're
cutting pasting it you're not leaving us
out to dry right so we I wrote Tom's
Senate sorry and it was with the hashtag
pray for Joe Wow and that pray for Joe
went [ __ ] viral like it's on the end
of my special on the end of my special
that I could you that want to thank and
I wrote a
- thank - titty Tom the Welch and
hashtag pray for Joe and the crazy thing
was that you go to hashtag pray for Joe
if there's also tons of like people that
have been hit by cars named Joe and
stuff like that who are in all these
like hospital beds and then there's Joe
Rogan with no like the Dalai Lama
so it's okay it's a really odd you can
get really caught up in there I went to
the pray for Joe hashtag one time and
enough spending like probably almost
$2,000 in GoFundMe campaigns so dude I
can't even I don't know what - I don't
blame you it's I'm telling you man and I
we know I think one of the things people
enjoy about that sober October and about
these bets that me and Joe and Ari and
Tom make is that it sets up the joke for
them to join along and they can make fun
of the comics they love like Joe or Tom
or Ari or even myself and then and they
know that we get it that we know it's a
joke right and so and they make us laugh
and then we repost good ones and people
are like little people come up with me
in Greece but like bro do you remember
the the picture where Joe was up front
and you and Ari were in Vietnam and Joe
was it was Apocalypse Now and I was like
yeah and they're like I made that you're
like oh [ __ ] dude and I we follow a lot
of those guys like Photoshop Steve
that's all right guys there's a lot of
really great artists out there that we
all just got into because they make
awesome [ __ ] photo shops dude Adi
Brock's Diab rocks there's a man there
yeah there's a conflict follow them all
because whatever they post the ones with
Talia the guys that [ __ ] with Talia make
me laughing Sarah oh do when I go on the
road and I get videos with stuff with
people it's always like [ __ ] Talia all
of them [ __ ] Rapoport